PROFESSOR: All right.
Today I think is the
last lecture at least
for the while about
origami, and I'm
going to talk about
where I got started
thinking about
organic mathematics.
The folding cup
problem, and this
is sort of motivated
by a magic trick.
The idea is you take
a piece of paper.
You fold it flat.
You make one complete
straight cut.
You cut along a line.
And you unfold the
pieces, and the question
is what shapes can you
get by that process.
So this is like a magic trick.
I showed you making a
swan which I have here
just for-- to jog your memory.
You have a rectangle paper, and
you can see the swan on there
and you can see a
bunch of creases.
You fold along all the
creases, not the swan lines,
and you end up with all
the edges of the swan lying
right along that line.
You cut along the line,
and you get your swan,
as we did before.
And you also get the anti-swan.
The other piece-- I didn't
show that last time.
But it's really--
it's not like we're
making we're not allowed
to make any extra creases.
We really want the swan.
So we cut along exactly
the edges of the swan
by lining them up onto a line.
So really, you could think
of this as a magic trick
in cutting, but you
can also think of it
as an origami
problem, which is I
want to line up all
these edges by folding.
How do I do it?
And that way it connects to a
lot origami design problems.
This problem has an old history.
It goes back to 1721.
This is the oldest
reference we know.
This is a Japanese puzzle
book, Wakoku Chiyekurabe
by Kan Chu Sen.
And I think this is
kind of like-- it's
called "Mathematical
Contests" is the translation.
And it's sort of
like the old version
of like these big
problem solving sessions
that kids do these days
to get better at math,
and one of the pages
poses this problem.
I have this Japanese
emblem shape.
Can I make it from
a piece of paper
by folding in one straight
cut, and the answer is yes.
And this is a solution
if you cheat and look
in the back of the book.
So I'll let you read
that for minute.
[LAUGHS]
You're making folds
along lines that end up
lining up other
parts of the shape
so that in the end everything
lies along the line,
then you cut along the line.
We learned about
this a bit later
than the-- we learned about
this problem from Martin Gardner
originally, and he knew
about the magic world.
So Houdini, before he
was an escape artist,
he was a general magician, and
in 1922, he wrote or probably
had ghost written this book,
"Houdini's Paper Magic".
And one of the pages is about
folding, and it says here,
you can take a square
paper, fold it flat,
make one straight cut, and get
a regular five-pointed star.
And that was pretty cool,
and then other magicians
picked it up, in particular
this guy Gerald Lowe, who
wrote this book "Paper Capers".
It's more like a
very small book.
Magic book.
And he could make all
sorts of different things
and he would incorporate
them into magic tricks.
And he was primarily
using simple folds.
He would just fold along
one line at a time,
and make one
straight cut, and go
to make all these cool patterns.
Like here, I have one
of his examples redone.
I start from a rectangle,
I fold, I fold, I fold,
I fold-- these are
all simple folds.
I take my scissors, and I make
one complete straight cut.
And usually when I perform
this trick, I say look!
I made an isosceles triangle.
Wow!
I made five isosceles triangles.
Amazing!
And then I made
everything, except the five
isosceles triangles.
So you saw that coming.
And you could make an
arrangement of five of these
if you want.
All that sort of
very symmetric stuff
is easy to do by simple folds.
I'll talk more about
simple folds later,
but we were really curious
about the general challenge.
So this is the-- you can
download this from my web page
if you want to make one.
It's pretty-- it's a fun trick.
Good.
So I have some more
interesting examples.
See here I have a
rectangle folded,
and I make one
complete straight cut.
And this one has actually
a line of symmetry,
so I fold in half
at the beginning.
So I get an angel fish.
Ooh!
All right, you're not impressed.
Keep going.
Here's another one.
One straight cut.
We could go all day here.
I mean, the point
of today's lecture
is to see how this is done.
In general.
Here we have a butterfly.
All right.
You guys are tough
to impress here.
Here we go.
This one is deemed thematic.
It's almost October, so
it's sort of appropriate.
We'll one straight cut.
Haven't done this
one for quite awhile.
Get tons of pieces, and if I'm
lucky-- open it up the right
way around.
Jack-o-lantern.
Wow, it's amazing!
How is it possible?
Obviously you can make
many shapes all at once.
That's the general idea here.
I'll admit, I cheated
here because I wanted kids
to be able to fold this.
The outer octagon
was cut initially.
Yeah, so it's not
from a rectangle.
Just to make it easier
to fold, but you
could do it all at once.
And now, the big demo.
In fact, it's so
big I think I might
want to use the exacto knife.
Uh, we'll try with scissors.
Got a lot of layers.
Oh, yeah.
This is why I usually
bring my own scissors.
Just checking the other side.
They're better scissors.
That's what's special
about my scissors.
All right, time for
the exacto knife.
Make sure I'm only
cutting on the boundary
between red and white.
Yeah, my lecture notes.
Yeah, who needs those?
It's flat.
A little more cutting.
I believe all the pieces in
this case are rectangles.
Exciting.
All right, straight cut, right?
I don't remember which
way this one opens.
This should be the MIT logo.
This one I encourage
you to try at home.
It's pretty crazy.
It's definitely a hard folding.
I'm getting used to it now.
All right, so you could
make anything is the point.
Some are a little more difficult
because they have more layers
and so on.
If I made it out of thinner
paper like some of the math
magicians do, it is super easy.
Onion skin paper or something.
I think I have some pictures
of the piece patterns
if you want to see
what these look like.
And these are all
available for download.
You want to impress
your friends, go for it.
They all use slightly
different color codings,
but it's mountain or valley.
And so we want to see
how to make these.
So let me state
the theorem first.
We have our good friend,
the universality result,
which is any set of line
segments on your piece of paper
can be-- I'll phrase it as can
be aligned by flat folding.
A line means when you
make the flat folding,
all the segments come
onto a common line.
Nothing else comes to that
line, and therefore you
cut a long line, you get
exactly those line segments.
And there are two methods
for solving this problem.
The first one is what I call
straight skeleton method,
and second one I'll call
the disk packing method.
By slightly different authors.
This one was me, my dad, and
my advisor, Anna [INAUDIBLE].
This one was Marshall Burn,
me, David Epstein, Barry Hayes.
This one's slightly
after this one.
This is sort of my first
computational origami paper.
And they're quite different.
I mean at a high level,
this one's practical.
This one is theoretically
good, but impractical.
This one's actually
theoretically
bad in a few situations
which we will get to,
but it works very
well almost always.
In a formal sense
of almost always.
This one always works, but
it's a challenge to fold.
All of the examples
I showed you are
made with the straight
skeleton method.
So that's the idea.
That's where we're going
to talk about both of them.
And first, I have a warm
up-- three warm ups.
Suppose you had a
square paper and you
wanted to make a single cut.
What folding do I do?
Nothing!
Yeah, that was easy.
Let's say I have two
lines I want to make.
What should I do?
Fold between them.
Fold the lines onto each other,
which is angular bisector.
If I extend the lines, and
I bisect the angle there,
then I will fold one
line to the other.
I brought one just to
be totally obvious.
You have two lines
fold along the angular
bisector of their extensions.
It lines up the lines,
and nothing else.
OK, a little more exciting.
What if I had a triangle?
How would you line up the edges
the triangle and nothing else?
Rabbit ear.
Yes.
Rabbit ear is you fold
along the three angular
bisectors of the triangle.
This is something we talked
about in the tree method.
This is one of the
sort of gadgets
we use in one of-- where
these were active paths.
And we fold along those
angular bisectors.
Angular bisectors
intuitively are
very good because locally
they line up edges.
So if I fold along
all three of them,
and you may know that they
always meet at a point,
then I kind of line
up all those edges.
If I just fold along
those three edges,
it won't be flat foldable.
It's like this floppy thing.
And so I've added in
these perpendicular--
the purple lines--
to give me my hinges
so I can manipulate these arms.
You don't have to
use all of them.
Then you flatten it,
and now along this line
are all the black guys.
All the black lines.
We've got a bunch
of flat foldings.
All right, so a general idea,
and in the straight skeleton
method, what we are going
to use are angular bisectors
and perpendicular folds.
Perpendicular folds are also
good because locally folds
are a reflection
if you fold flat.
So this line will fold
on top of this line.
So perpendiculars are good.
Angular bisectors are good.
If you fold along all of them,
you should line everything up.
That's the intuition,
and the question
is how do I fold a long
enough angular bisectors
and perpendiculars so that
it actually folds flat.
And that is the straight
skeleton, or one way
to do that is the
straight skeleton.
And this actually was
invented a few years earlier.
95, 96 by a couple of Austrians.
That was in [INAUDIBLE]
and actually four people.
So let me write
down a definition,
and then we will-- I'll
show you what it means.
We've seen a thing
like this very briefly
in the universal
molecule, but this
is going to be more
general in some sense.
And actually, why don't
I put up an image of one
while we're defining it.
All right, so it is trajectory
of the vertices of the desired
cut pattern-- that's our input.
The graph of edges
we want to cut out.
As we simultaneously
shrink each region.
That's every face
outlined by those cuts.
Keeping edges parallel and a
uniform perpendicular distance
from the original edges.
So, a bit of a mouthful, but
let me draw some pictures.
Well, let's maybe
start with a triangle.
So the idea with
a triangle is you
shrink-- this is really the
wrong order to do things.
I want to shrink-- there's
two regions for the triangle.
There's the inside
and the outside.
If I shrink the inside, I
get these parallel lines.
All-- I want all of these
distances to be equal.
Those are the
perpendicular distances.
I keep shrinking,
and at some point
I can't shrink anymore
because I get a single point.
The in-center of the triangle.
If I watch where did the
vertices go during that time,
it's along angular bisectors.
Hey, our good friends,
angular bisectors.
Now I do the same
thing on the outside.
Shrinking the outside region
is like expanding the triangle.
As I expand the triangle, the
outside gets smaller area.
So actually, it's
just the same thing.
I get concentric
triangles, and I just
keep going along the
angular bisectors.
So that's it.
It's not going to give us
the perpendicular fold.
It's just the angular
bisector parts.
Still see a triangle
in there somewhere.
OK, that's a really
simple example,
and the only event
that happened is
that the polygon disappeared.
When that happens, you stop
with that particular polygon.
In general, there are three
things that can happen.
We call these events.
Three interesting.
Things.
One is that an edge disappears.
So for example, locally, if
I have a picture like this
and I shrink, and I shrink,
and I shrink, at some point--
what's happening is these
angular bisectors are meeting,
and now I lost-- this edge
shrinks to zero length.
So just forget about the edge.
Pretend it was never there.
Just keeps shrinking now
what is these two edges.
And I shrink, and I
shrink, and I shrink.
What happens is, in some
sense, these vertices
merge-- these edges
merge, and now I
have one guy going
straight up there.
And what is that edge doing?
It's not an angular
bisector of this or this,
but it's an angular bisector
of the extension of these two
lines.
Because if you look at this--
one of these two edges--
they are parallel
to the two original.
So if you bisect those
parallel offsets,
it's the same thing as
bisecting the original edges
and extension.
So this looks good because
these two folds will line up
those two edges, or this fold
will line up these two edge.
This fold will line
up those two edges.
up these two edges.
And we're doing kind
of extra alignment,
but everything looks kosher.
Good.
So when an edge disappears,
you just forget about it.
All right, forget-- it's
probably "forgedaboutit"--
something like that.
All right.
Then we have-- a
region can disappear.
That's what happened
with the triangle.
And then again, you
forget about it.
There may be many regions.
You have to keep shrinking
the other regions,
but when one
disappears, you're done.
Third thing that can happen
is that a region splits.
So let's look at an
interesting polygon.
This one-- the straight edges.
And when I shrink this
guy-- see, what's happening
is this edge is approaching
that vertex, and at some point
they will meet.
And what we're left with are
two triangles in this case.
And generally split
into two parts,
you just keep
shrinking the parts.
So it's not really like
you're stopping at any point.
Just the same thing
over and over.
But if you're implementing
this on a computer,
you really have to
realize that happens.
Otherwise you'd shrink
them beyond each other
and it would be self
intersecting and ugly.
But you do the
obvious thing, which
is you cut where they split.
And what will happen in this
case with straight skeleton
is you keep going along
an angular bisector
until that little
triangle stops.
One more edge here.
So that's what the straight
skeleton will look like.
This edge is an angular bisector
of this one and this one.
In general, if you
look at an edge,
and you see what
original edge can I
reach without crossing
another skeleton edge,
those are the two
that you bisect.
So it's really easy to see.
Look at this guy.
The only two I can reach
are this one and this one.
I look at this one, the
only two I can reach
are that one and that one.
So it's an angular
bisector of those two.
In fact, in general, if you
finish the outside here too,
it's the same deal.
And then-- yeah,
all right, enough.
Here's a bigger example.
Little turtle drawn
on a triangular grid,
and you can see there's
angular bisectors.
This is a straight skeleton.
This guy, for example,
bisects this horizontal edge
and this horizontal edge has a
little bit of a boundary case
we have to think about, but this
is the right interpretation.
It's like an angle of 180,
so you bisect it to 90.
Other fun features.
Here we get a
little bit of action
on the outside of the polygon.
So far, we haven't seen that.
So, like these guys
meet, and there
is some bigger-- there's a
bigger turtle here somewhere.
It's hard to draw.
Anyway, what's
happening is this edge
is shrinking to zero while this
one is offsetting down this way
and this is offsetting
down this way.
So the new turtle ends
up being like that.
And so on.
You're shrinking every face.
So in general, you have a
whole bunch of polygons.
Or in general we're
allowing crazy things
like this as this pattern
of cuts I want to make.
Maybe you want to cut your
square into five pieces.
I'm going to shrink each of
them separately, or in parallel.
It doesn't actually matter.
So in this case
there's just going
to be five angular bisectors.
In general, there are several
regions you shrink all of them.
A lot of the time we
think about polygons,
and then there's two
regions to shrink.
And it looks like you're
expanding the turtle to go out,
but really you're shrinking
the outside region.
It just happens to be--
there's one infinite
region that one looks weird.
A couple other special
cases, because I
want to do any graph
and not just polygons.
You could have something
that just terminates.
So a degree one vertex only
has one [? edge ?] into it.
In this case, it's
not quite well
defined what to do
because you offset this
and you offset this,
but what happens here?
And there it's
sort of arbitrary.
You can do whatever you
want, but the simplest thing
you can do is to make
a-- imagine that there's
a little vertical segment here
that happens to be length zero,
and it expands into the
edge of a rectangle.
So you end up with these
245 degree angular bisectors
between this vertical edge
and the horizontal one.
But you have some
flexibility there.
You can design it how you want.
The other case you can
have is a degree 0 vertex.
There are no edges here.
This is a little funny
in the way I defined it.
I just said I wanted
to align line segments.
You could also align points
if you really feel like it,
and that would be
represented by a dot that
has no cuts next to it.
If you want to cut
out just this point--
I need to make it something.
You could think of it as a
tiny triangle for consistency
with this picture.
We think of it as
a little square.
And so, when you
expand it, or when
you shrink the outside region,
you get four 45 degrees folds.
This is actually how
[? Eichholtz ?] et al defined
it back in '96, and
it's a fine definition.
But you have flexibility
here in your design process.
They'll all work.
And this would let you take a
whole bunch of points, align
them onto a common line, and
nothing else is on that line.
Because these folds are
going to push everything
that's surrounding the
point away from the line.
All right.
Some fun facts.
Straight skeleton
is nice and small.
If you have n original
points and line segments
in your desired cut pattern,
the straight skeleton
has a linear n number of
line segments-- linear number
of creases.
So order n.
Other fun facts-- there is
a one-to-one correspondence
between the edges you
want to cut along,
like let me pick
one over here maybe.
Like this-- this is an
edge I want to cut along,
and regions of the
straight skeleton.
So here's a region.
A face of the straight skeleton.
This guy.
There's exactly one cut
edge inside of that.
That's always the case.
You look everywhere here.
Every region of the
straight skeleton-- it's
more obvious if I color
them different colors.
There's one cut edge inside.
And all of those guys that
surround that cut edge
bisect that edge
and another one.
And the other one is the
one on the other side.
In general, you take one of
the straight skeleton edges.
There are two sides.
There's two faces of
the straight skeleton.
This one's crazy and non convex.
This one's just a little
infinite triangle down here,
and that edge bisects
those two cut edges.
So it's very easy to walk
around the structure.
See what it bisects.
lots of things get bisected.
But, it's not flat
foldable, so we're not done.
And that's where we
need the perpendiculars.
So--
I'll write down the
definition, and maybe
show the picture
we're going for.
There's a lot of
structures here.
There is what I
call the cut graph--
the things we're trying to make.
Then there's the
straight skeleton.
You should think of it as
a graph drawn on a paper.
It has vertices of
straight skeleton,
which is called
skeleton vertices.
Regions of straight
skeleton, which
is called skeleton regions.
Edges of the cut
graph, which are called
cut edges, and so on.
We're going to add
a new graph, which
is the perpendicular graph.
Which you can think
of as hinges from tree
method of origami design.
So what is this--
what does it mean?
We started a straight
skeleton vertex.
Usually there are three
skeleton edges coming together.
Vertex-- sometimes they're
more like this guy.
Four.
And if there's three
edges coming together,
there are three
skeleton regions.
For each one-- each
of those regions--
has one cut edge
in it, so we try
to walk perpendicular
and toward that cut edge.
So here I walk perpendicular.
I meet at right angles here.
I just go off to infinity.
Here I walk perpendicular to
this cut edge, and that's cool,
but then I leave
the skeleton region.
At that point I enter
a new skeleton region,
which is this one,
this non-convex thing.
It contains one et edge, and
when I-- where was I here?
I entered.
Now I want to move
perpendicular to that cut edge,
so that when I cross it, I
cross it perpendicularly.
Now I enter a new region.
It contains this cut edge.
I move perpendicular to it,
and I don't actually cross it,
but I enter a new region.
Now I'm in the region
of this cut edge,
so I move perpendicular to that.
And wow, I hit another
skeleton vertex.
I stop.
OK this example is because
it's on a triangular grid,
there's lots of
degeneracies like that.
Usually you'd eventually
go off to infinity,
or come around to meet yourself.
Here I happen to hit
a different vertex.
You do that all the vertices.
All the skeleton vertices.
Now there's some weird
ones like this one.
Notice there are no purple
lines coming out from here,
and that's because
every region you
try to enter you
immediately leave.
So if I tried-- there's
four regions here.
Try each one of them.
Like this region
has this cut edge.
If I try to go
perpendicular to it,
I'd enter a different region,
so I can actually go at all.
Like I move and then
I instantly stop.
So you could think of there
being like a zero radius
thing there.
That's sort of the
degenerate case
of a river being a disc
Is it being a circle.
Same thing going on.
All of-- in general
when you have
reflex vertices and their
regular bisectors meeting,
you're going to lose
some perpendiculars
because you can't enter them.
Here's another one where I
just have one perpendicular
edge coming out.
This one I can
reach, but if I tried
to be perpendicular
to either of these,
I enter the wrong region.
That's the perpendicular
folds, and that's pretty much
the crease pattern.
There are technically
a few other folds
you have to deal
with, but that is--
if you want to make
something right now,
just apply those two algorithms
and you get your shape.
Just fold along
that crease pattern.
It will be flat
foldable almost always.
Why is it flat foldable?
So one thing we can check is
local flat foldability at least
satisfies Kawasaki's condition
because at a typical vertex
you're going to have three
skeleton edges coming together.
And so there are
three faces here.
Each of them has a cut edge
somewhere-- probably draw
this reasonably well-- and
should have the property
that when I extend these--
didn't draw that so well.
And I extend these-- these
are angular bisectors.
We know the skeleton edges will
angularly bisect two cut edges.
The two cut edges that
are defined by these guys.
So I should get an angular
bisector here, and those meet.
An angular bisector here.
And then I also have
perpendicular folds.
So they may not actually meet
this guy, but if they did,
they certainly
meet the extension.
Hey, that's our good
friend, the rabbit ear.
Just regular triangle fold.
And in particular, you can see
that these angles are equal.
I call this three prime.
It's like 180 minus
that, I think.
If I'm not mistaken.
And this is one prime.
Not the best notation.
And these are two
prime and two prime.
And so I've got these
nice angle pairings.
That means if I add the odd
angles, I get the even angles.
Same thing.
So I definitely have
Kawasaki's theorem everywhere.
You could check--
it works even when
you have these degenerate
situations where
more than three skeleton
edges come together.
For the same reason.
You still get pairing.
Just more than three of them.
All right.
But some exciting
things can happen.
So I'm going to look
at proving foldability,
but one exciting
thing that can happen
is you get a lot of
perpendicular folds at a very
few original cut lines.
So here I'm trying to make
this weird pinwheel shape.
I want to cut out the bold
lines of the cut line.
So I want to cut
out this square,
and then these four squares
arranged in a pinwheel pattern
around that one.
Why you'd want to do that?
I don't know, but we're
mathematicians so we're
going to consider all the cases.
So the straight skeleton
is the thin black lines,
and that's linear size.
That's nice, but
the perpendiculars--
if this piece of
paper's infinite,
the number of
perpendiculars is infinite.
If you have a finite
piece of paper,
which is what you
usually buy in the store,
then it's a finite
number of creases.
So in any finite region, this
is a finite number of creases,
but it's a lot of them.
So that's one sad thing.
You can't bound the
number of creases
as a function of the
number of cut lines.
But I think that's
actually necessary.
I don't think it's possible
to solve this problem
while bounding the
number of creases
in terms of the
number of cut lines.
That's one of the open
problems getting down
on one of these pictures.
One of these slide--
lecture notes.
There's something else
even more annoying, though.
It happens even in a
finite piece of paper,
and it's even more obscure
why you'd want to make this.
But the bold blue
lines are the cuts,
and then the thin black lines
are the straight skeleton.
You could tell this
spans many years
because I keep changing
notational style,
and this is from the textbook.
And then you get these
perpendicular folds.
So I haven't drawn all
of them but these dash
lines, the light blue.
And this example is set up so
that-- let me get this right.
This width is an
irrational multiple
of this width or this width.
One of those.
Things are irrational, so
they're not very nice numbers.
And what I need to do
to finish this picture
is these guys go-- they
enter a new skeleton region.
They're actually going
to keep going straight
because there's two cut
lines that are parallel
to each other.
It's going to go up there, and
it's going to cycle around.
Let me do one round.
Who did I move?
This guy.
So this guy I just
extended down.
He's going to turn around,
make 180 degree turn,
and you can check each of these.
Your setups do 180 degree
turn around this axis,
around this axis on the bottom,
and on the top around this axis
and around this axis.
Depending wherever you
enter, it's like a racetrack.
Keep going around and around.
And if you follow that one
guy a little bit farther,
it looks like that.
And a little bit farther,
and it looks like that.
It never finishes.
So in fact you completely
filled this region with creases.
It's like a dense
region of creases.
Now this would be
a bitch to fold.
I don't recommend you try it.
And this is really a situation
where this algorithm fails.
The good news is if I move
any of these vertices--
the cut vertices the tiniest
amount-- this will disappear.
I really had to be very careful
and get lots of degeneracy
for this to happen.
We don't actually know
how to prove that.
It's conjecture that if you take
any cuts-- any graph of cuts
you want to make, and
you perturb the vertices
in a tiny epsilon disc then
the resulting thing will not
have this density behavior.
I'm totally sure it's true,
but we don't have the proof.
So that's life.
This is why I said skeleton
method works almost always.
There are these
annoying situations
where it doesn't really
give your crease pattern.
So if you feel like
unless you somehow
think this is legitimate to
make infinitely many creases.
I don't think so.
All right, let me tell
you a few more things
to make this practical for you.
You want to-- what
you really want
is a mountain valley assignment.
Before I showed you lots of
perpendicular and skeleton
edges, and basically
the way it works
is if you look at any
skeleton edge like this one,
it's bisecting in this
case a convex angle.
So I make it a mountain.
Here, red is mountain,
blue is valley.
Dot dashes mountain,
dash is valley.
That is the standard.
Whenever I'm bisecting
a reflex angle,
then I make the
skeleton edge a valley.
And that's basically true.
Convex angles, mountains,
reflex angles, valleys.
That's for the straight
skeleton edges.
Yeah.
Like this fold, or this one?
Oh, this guy.
All right, this is a
bit of a special case.
Here I'm really bisecting
an angle of zero.
To extend these guys out,
they need an infinite,
and they form a zero angle
because they're parallel.
And I call zero a convex angle,
but I just defined it that way,
and so this is a mountain.
Whereas this guy bisecting
is barely convex.
Is that really a mountain?
No, that's a typo.
Good.
This one should be a valley.
Pretty sure.
Yeah, should be a valley-- wow,
this is a weird crease pattern.
That's not a straight
skeleton there.
Never mind this picture-- I
knew there was always a bug.
I think there's a typo
in the book as we say.
How did I make the initial
pattern of the turtle?
I just drew something
that looked like a turtle.
Anything.
I happened to draw
this on a grid,
but there's no reason I had to.
I designed them.
So in this example, I designed
the ratios to be really nasty.
Like root 2 over 10
ratio or something.
The whole thing will-- if I
perturb these vertices at all,
the whole thing will fall apart.
I won't get these
180 degree turns.
Things will end up
going off to infinity.
The hard part here is
actually-- rational ratios
are quite common.
What's uncommon
in this picture is
that this thing is closed
up, and you never escape.
Almost always, there'll
be a little gap
and you'll eventually
reach the gap
and then go off to infinity.
So that's what happens
in a typical case.
So if you drew a picture on the
grid this would never happen.
That you can prove.
Yeah.
Square grid.
Probably also the
triangular grid.
You need to be a little
careful because you
want all these constructions
to stay on the grid,
but I think something
like that is true.
OK, let's move on to how we
construct a folded state.
When this algorithm works,
when it gives a valid crease
pattern, you know it's
locally flat foldable
because it satisfies
Kawasaki, but how
do we actually know that
it globally folds flat?
To do that, you have
to describe what
it looks like after it's folded.
And the idea here is to look at
what we call corridors but are
essentially discrete versions
of rivers from tree theory.
So you have these
constant width strips
that turn at skeleton
edges, and they
could go off to
infinity on both sides.
In general they could loop
around and meet themselves
again, but in this case they
actually all go to infinity.
And if you look at
one of those strips--
you could actually just cut
this out of your textbook.
Just slice it up and look
at how that's folding.
Well, it meets a skeleton
edge, and then maybe it
meets a cut edge.
Usually you don't fold those.
Then it meets another
skeleton edge.
It just meets edges
one at a time.
It's never
complicated because we
divided along all these
perpendicular folds.
You really only meet
one edge at a time.
Which is good.
In fact, if you look at
one of these skeleton edges
it's creased along,
normally you think
of that as an angular bisector
of these two cut edges,
but you can also think of
it as an angular bisector
of these two
perpendicular folds.
Because if you bisect
these two things,
you also bisect two things
that are perpendicular to them.
It's like two wrongs
make a right somehow.
So this guy bisects
those two creases.
So if you fold along
here-- actually
you align these creases.
It's a duality-- you are
aligning the perpendicular
folds.
That fold along here, you line
up this fold with that one,
this fold with that one.
I fold here, I lined up
There's like a zero
length fold that's there.
You fold along all these things.
You line up this with
itself, and so on.
So you follow along this thing.
This corridor folds down
to basically a rectangle.
It's got some rough edges
in the top and the bottom,
but it lies in the strip in 3D,
and I have a picture of that.
So I took the one over
here-- this blue corridor--
and if you fold it up,
it looks like this.
OK, now in particular, you
can check at this point.
It's pretty easy
to check because
of all this bisectorness--
Bisector goodness--
that you bring into
alignment all the cut edges.
So for example, this guy,
because it bisects that cut
edge and that cut edge, it
brings them into alignment.
And you can see that
somewhere in this picture.
I think it's these two guys.
It can be a little
more complicated.
Like over here I
have a cut edge,
then I have a bisector, and
then a bisector, and then
a bisector, and then
another cut edge.
But if you think about it right,
it's-- I don't happen to meet
these cut edges, but I'm
effectively bringing this
into alignment with this, and
then this into alignment with
this, and then this into
alignment with that.
So in the end, I
line this with that,
and that's what's happening
up here on the left.
Where I don't quite
come all the way down,
but I still end up
lining everything up.
So this is the solution to
the fold-and-cut problem
as long as it actually faults.
And to show that
actually folds, you just
need to show that these
corridors-- I forget,
I think we call
these accordions.
It's been a long time.
Since '98 I wrote this paper
You take these
accordions and you just
want to see how
they fit together.
And low and behold,
they fit together
in a tree in this picture.
It gets more complicated
in another picture, which
I will show you in a moment.
But in this situation where
every quarter goes off
to infinity on both sides,
you get a nice tree structure.
And as long as you could
fold this tree flat,
then you can fold
this thing flat.
Because each of these
edges of the tree
is this very simple
accordion structure
which trivially falls flat.
The other thing you
have to check here
is you actually alternate
mountain valley.
That's a little more
subtle, especially
when I don't draw the
mountain valley assignment.
But it turns out you always
alternate between mountain
and valley in this
picture, which is great.
That's the thing we
know always folds flats.
It's like a 1D folding.
So these are super easy to fold.
You can fold each of them if
you cut along all the dash
lines You can fold
each separately.
Then you need to
join them together
where the edges here-- just like
in tree theory-- the edges here
correspond to these rivers.
And now you need to
somehow attach them here.
Check that where you attach
them, there's no crossings.
I'm not going to describe,
but it's pretty easy.
Plain area essentially
of that diagram,
and then you need to
fold this tree flat.
Folding a tree flat
is actually kind
of a segue into
next lecture, which
will be about folding linkages.
In this case, it's really easy.
You just pick up some root,
like the letter "A" over there,
and you hang the tree.
Pull up.
Technically this is like a
[? depth ?] [? first ?] search
of the tree.
So you just walk
down-- aways walk down
until you're finished,
then you go back up.
Walk down some more branches.
You end up drawing everything
downward away from A.
And it will be a flat folding.
There won't be any
crossings here.
And then this is a
1D representation
of what's really
going on, which is
that above each of these
edges is really an accordion,
and you need to adjoin
them together there.
So we'll basically do
this modular folding
where you fold each
accordion separately,
put them together
according to this.
Boom, you get your flat folding.
From this picture, you could
read out the mountain valley
assignments before the
perpendicular folds.
This looks like a
valley, this looks
like a valley-- this looks
like a perpendicular fold
I didn't use because
there's no crease there.
That's flat.
Whereas a mountain-- mountain's
probably at the top at A.
What really happens-- if
you want to know-- really
what we're deciding is whether
this starts mountain or valley,
and then it will actually
alternate back and forth
as you move along
the perpendicular.
So that's basically how you
construct a folded state.
In this situation of
so-called linear corridors.
Now there are a bunch of
things I haven't mentioned,
but I think-- I don't
want to talk about them
too much so I get out
to the other topics.
So, what I just talked
about is something called
a linear corridor
case, which is really
where it's most beautiful--
this construction
of a folded state-- and
linear corridor intuitively
is something like this.
It goes off to
infinite on both sides.
Has constant width all the way.
Of course, it's really
a discrete thing.
Not a smooth thing.
Let me say
conjecture-- if you're
cut graph has that
maximum degree
2-- it means at most two
edges at every vertex.
This is a very common scenario.
This is if you want
to make a polygon,
every vertex has degree 2.
If you want to make
several polygons,
every vertex has degree 2.
I'll even let you have vertices
of degree 1 or 0 for free,
but mainly we're thinking
about degree 2 everywhere.
Then, we almost always
have a linear corridor.
So this is why the
situation's interesting,
although unfortunately
this is still a conjecture.
I'm sure this is
true, but proving it--
I don't quite know
the right techniques.
So in this typical situation,
you take any picture you want.
You slightly perturb very
vertex randomly, say,
then with probability
1-- 100% probability--
you will get only
linear corridors.
And that's the situation
where it turns into a tree.
It's easy to fold life is good.
The annoying case is
circular corridor case.
This takes a lot
more work to prove,
and I'm not going to
talk about it much.
A circular corridor
looks like this.
Here we have these
in with rivers also.
So you just loop around.
Still constant width everywhere,
but you meet yourself.
You don't go out to infinity.
It's harder.
Why is it harder?
Well in particular, if you
look at how one corridor folds,
it's no longer-- it's
like the same situation we
had in like lectures
two and three
where we had on the one hand
a 1D folding was really easy.
But then when you
made it circular--
you're just folding a circle
instead of folding a line
segment-- now you had
this wrap around issue.
So, like, these guys
would have to line up.
It turns out they will
line up because everything
is bisecting and whatnot.
These edges will
line up, but now you
have to join them together.
And if this part went all the
way down here and came back up,
then you'd get an intersection.
And it turns out, in general,
I get a choice of who's first
and who's last.
I have a circular
order of things,
and I get to choose where
I break that circular order
and make it a linear order.
Where I do the wrap around.
There's some
circular corridors--
you can't even break
them and make it work.
Kind of depressing.
So this is definitely harder
and that sometimes it's
not possible.
But we can save a
little bit, which
is-- I don't have
an example handy.
I wish I did.
I'll have to reconstruct it.
This is so long ago.
Here's a way to make
it definitely work.
Fold all the cut edges.
So far in the pictures
I've been drawing,
I didn't fold
along the cut edges
because I really wanted to
separate the green region here
from the yellow region.
If I folded this up-- this
is quite a complicated one
to fold-- you get the cut lines
somewhere like over there,
and then the green stuff will
be always above the cut line
and the yellow stuff will
be below the cut line.
In general, this is
called a side assignment.
You have a bunch of
regions you decide
which ones you want
to be above and which
ones you want to be below.
And usually, you have
polygons, and you
say the interiors are above
and the exteriors are below.
But in general, you could
ask for anything you want.
You could say maybe I want
both of these to be above.
If you make both
of them above, you
have to valley fold along
all of the cut lines.
So if you do that-- you say
I want all regions to be
above the cut line-- you
can still line them up.
You end up folding along all
the cut edges with valleys.
And then wrap around
is super easy.
We take this thing, and in
fact, everyone's folding
along the black lines.
So really everybody
comes down to the floor,
and then the wrap around is
just underneath the floor
and life is good.
So that's one way to
deal with this case,
and you have to
prove that works.
It's complicated.
I would rather go
onto other topics.
I do think this would
make a fun project.
It's not easy to make
these crease patterns.
Currently we draw
them always by hand,
meaning with the fancy
drawing program that
knows how to do
angular bisectors.
And it's an art to
move around the points
so that you get
lots of alignments.
Like when you get four straight
skeleton edges coming together,
that means you
get fewer creases.
That's a good thing whenever
you can make that happen.
So when you could give
me software to help
do that, I would love you.
So let's move on.
Any questions about the
straight skeleton method?
Now I'm going to switch
over to disk packing.
All right.
Same problem, but
now I'll give you
a method that always
works in theory.
Just difficult in practice.
I think this is good
chalk because it's yellow.
Generally, if it's
yellow on the outside
it is railroad chalk,
which is the good stuff.
But, what the problem
is-- we have bad erasers.
It's persistence of vision.
You just get to remember
what I used to write.
I don't want to write
down the algorithms.
It's complicated.
I want to give you a visual
overview of the main steps.
I guess there's nice
figures do that for us.
So we start with a
very complicated shape
we want to make, like
this quadrilateral.
And you can see disk
packing is involved.
The very first thing we do-- and
I'll tell you why in a moment--
is thicken the graph
you want to build.
So maybe it's a
polygon, maybe it's
a graph-- I'll think about
the polygon case for now
because it's easier, then I'll
come back to the general case.
I thicken it by tiny epsilon.
Just offset in both directions.
Just like as if you're starting
the straight skeleton method,
but then you stop after epsilon.
No events happen
in epsilon time.
OK, then I have this picture--
the purple stuff, pink stuff,
whatever.
Magenta.
50% magenta.
I happen to know I
drew this figure.
Now I'm going to take
some 50% cyan disks
and pack them to
fill this region.
Now what I want-- there's
three properties I want.
One is that every
vertex, but you
have to think about
each region separately
which is a little bit confusing.
Let's think about the outside.
It's a little easier.
Bigger.
Every vertex of this
graph on the outside
should be the center of a disk.
There's a disk center here.
there's a disk center here,
and a disk center there.
On the inside it's also true,
they're just different disks.
Then also I want the
edges of the graph
to be covered by
a radii of disks.
And so here's a
radius of one disk.
Here's a diameter of a disc.
Here's a radius of a disk
that covers the edge.
So in other words, I
want to fill-- along
the edge I want to
have a bunch of centers
so that I completely
cover that edge with blue.
You'll see why later.
Question?
The disks have to
be non-overlapping.
These properties are actually
quite challenging to achieve.
Your question is why
do we use small disks.
Disk, because if I
had a big disk here,
it would intersect this disk.
Now I didn't have to
make that disk so big,
but if I made that
one smaller, I'd
have to have more disks here.
Or here there's also
two small disks.
That one I probably could have
gotten away with a bigger disk.
Oh, no, but then on the
inside you have a problem.
So these guys actually
have to match up.
That's another constraint.
And the inside and the
outside have to match up.
Here there's a slight
change in radii
to compensate for the epsilon.
Along the edges they're
exactly the same.
So if I made this
one a big disk,
it would overlap this one.
So I could make that one
smaller, but then-- other
problems.
So you have to
simultaneously balance
all these constraints,
which is a bit exciting.
What else?
The discs don't overlap.
And the last property is that
the gaps between the disks
have always three or four sides.
Why?
Because I want it to.
It will make life easier.
You could try to
deal with more sides,
but three and four is nice.
Yeah, I'll get to that.
Why do we care about
number of sides?
Because I'm going
to draw a graph.
I'm going to subdivide
my original graph here
with these red lines to
say whenever disks kiss,
I will draw-- connect the
centers of those disks.
And because these gaps always
have three or four sides--
it's not the best example.
Here's like three sides.
The red lines I draw
will outline a triangle.
Whenever I have three sides,
whenever I have four sides,
I'll have a quadrilateral.
So I've subdivided my
regions into triangles
and quadrilaterals.
OK, you have to believe
that this is possible.
I can sketch an
algorithm for you,
which is you draw a tiny
disk at each of the corners,
and then you draw lots of
tiny this along the edges
to fill the edges.
And that will
satisfy everything.
I mean the disks will
be non-overlapping
because they're super tiny.
They won't get near any other
disks from some other side.
And what other good things?
Oh, but the regions
will be ginormous.
They won't have
three or four sides.
They'll have 100 sides, a
million sides-- who knows.
Well, whenever you have
some crazy region outlined
by disks-- might not be convex.
Whatever-- just draw the
biggest disk you can in there.
I'll get it to turn
into a disk eventually.
That does not intersect
anybody, but if it's
the biggest possible,
it will actually
touch at least three sides.
If you degenerate,
it might touch four.
But in general, it will
touch three sides, which
will subdivide that
region into three pieces,
and you can show that those
pieces are all little bit
smaller than what you had before
in terms of number of sides.
Except when you start
with a quadrilateral.
When there's four
sides, you'll get
quadrilaterals and triangle.
So you can't go
below three and four.
It'd be great if we
could always get down
to three sides in
every region, but we
can get down to three or four.
Anything bigger than three
or four you can show.
This will make it
strictly smaller.
So that is an algorithm.
It's not super efficient, but
it will find a disk packing
with all these properties.
Then we do the subdivision.
Now what do you think
we're going to do?
What do we do with
the triangles?
Rabbit ear.
That's the key phrase for today.
So remember our good friend,
the rabbit ear, and then
there was the universal
molecule-- Lang's
universal molecule
for the quadrilateral.
We're going to use that
for the quadrilaterals.
And it turns out there's
some nice properties here,
which is the perpendicular
folds of the rabbit ear
will always hit right at the
kissing point between the two
disks.
And same thing in here.
We've got these four disks.
We've got this quadrilateral
region in between.
and the perpendicular folds that
come out of these two points.
You may not remember
exactly what's
happening here as we shrink.
And then in the tree method,
this became an active path.
There's no notion of
active paths here,
but we just make that so.
That these perpendicular folds
will end up hitting kissing
disks, and we'll end up actually
with the four arm starfish.
In terms of the tree you get and
the articulatable flaps here,
these guys will all
meet at a point.
That's just the way this
works with disk packing.
And you can think of
there being disks here
and you're actually applying
the tree method to that flap
pattern, and that's probably the
easiest way to think about it.
But what's good for us--
do I have a picture?
Not yet.
But the point is, I have
perpendiculars coming out
of here.
I have perpendiculars
coming out of here.
They will meet because these
disks kiss at the same point
up from both sides.
Perpendiculars meet.
That's good.
That means I don't
get perpendiculars
bouncing all over the place.
So all this work is to make
sure that perpendiculars
are well behaved.
It's a lot of work to
do it, but it does it.
Now when you fold this
thing, what we end up doing
is lining up-- remember there
was two copies of my polygon.
There's the inner copy
and the outer copy.
I end up lining up
all of these guys--
I'm got to go back
to the picture.
I'm sorry.
So we have this inner copy,
and what these molecules end up
doing is lining up all
the edges of this quad,
all the edges of this quad,
all the edges of this triangle.
All those edges
on the inside will
become lined up on one edge.
All the lines on
the outside become
lined up on another line.
Turns out it will be
parallel to that line.
But what we really wanted
to line up were these edges,
and you can see why we had to
do the outside of the beginning,
because otherwise we'd get
tons of extra junk on our line.
We only want these
edges on our line.
So we did the offset
so that all this stuff
will come to one line.
All this stuff on the outside
will come to another line.
And then we get this picture.
So this is one
line at the bottom.
Another line at the top.
We really wanted to line up
stuff-- the blue stuff there.
And there's still
some junk on our line.
These cyan triangles
represent things
that come from down
here, but we really
don't want them
to cross our line.
They just happened to.
So we have to sync
them repeatedly.
Do lots of folds to make them
underneath that epsilon line.
Then we can cut along
our line, and we're done.
Easy.
To prove that this works,
we'll view a little sketch.
This is kind of fun,
and it's one piece
of what we're in the process
of doing for tree maker.
This is sort of like a
special case of tree maker.
You just have very
simple molecules
and a relatively simple way
in which they're combined.
Here I've done a
simpler example.
I want to make a square, and I
end up decomposing in this case
into nine molecules-- nine
quadrilateral molecules.
A very simple disk
packing which I have not
shown the disk packing here.
The idea is I'm going to
make some cuts in my paper
to make my problem easier.
I'm going to have to pay for
that, because later I really
want those edges joined.
I'll have to glue
them back together.
But to make it easier think
about, I cut those four edges.
So that the way in which
my molecules are connected
to each other is a tree,
because I like trees.
They're easier to think about.
Easier to do induction over.
So that's the blue line
connecting the centers
in a tree.
The other remaining edges in
the grid have been cut away.
Now the idea is--
it's kind of like what
I was drawing for the
linear corridor case.
You have a tree, you pick
up the tree from some node,
and just hang it down.
And in this case, we hang
it from this molecule.
The red edges are
mountain, so three of these
are going to be valley.
One mountain.
The idea is this thing reaches
around the next guy, which
reaches is around the
next guy, which reaches
around the next guy,
and there's actually--
there's two valleys
here-- two little pockets.
Each of-- this guy
goes in that pocket,
this guy goes in that pocket,
and recursively, it just works.
I think I have a picture of
what's actually happening here.
Yeah, is it's hard
to really draw,
but each of these
forearm starfish
has one mountain
and three valleys,
and you just nestle inside
your parent in the tree.
And this is really easy to show
that there's no crossings here
because just joined
to your parent,
and it's a nice
nesting structure.
It's just in the same way
that trees can be folded flat.
You can fold all
these molecules flat
and join them
together in a tree.
But we didn't
really have a tree.
We had all those extra cuts
that we have to re-suture.
So we have this picture,
and now we really
have to join up these edges and
think about what the mountain
valley assignment is there.
And it works.
This green thing
is the boundary,
and then I have
connected the dots.
Each of these dots corresponds
to one green edge here.
I forget whether it's this
edge or that one, I think.
It's just a single edge.
And so, for example, these
two are-- these two joins,
and then the joins above
that nestle around it.
And then the other
branch at the top are
joins, and in the leftmost
cut are these two joins.
You have to make these
joins, and really
all you need to
check is that these
joins form a non-crossing
picture like they do here.
And that's almost obvious
because this is a planer
diagram and we're cutting
along a planer tree,
and so this is again a depth
first search kind of thing.
So there's one tree we
call the dual tree here
that works because it's
a tree, and then there's
the cuts you make which are
different trees-- primal tree
if you want-- and that also
works because of planarity.
And it all works.
That's the hand wavy version,
and you can read the textbook
if you want more details.
Oh, gosh.
If you want to solve more
general graphs, you can do it.
In general, you have to
offset all of those cut lines,
and you get all these things--
along the pink lines here you
line things up,
but you really want
to line up these blue
lines-- purple lines.
And so you have to do more
syncing to get it to work.
Now I have all the
things I want to line up
on this line and this line.
I fold in the middle,
and now they're lined up.
That fold in the middle--
yeah, that will work.
Good.
Might have to do more syncing.
Whew.
Questions about
disk-packing method?
This is a bit of
a whirlwind tour,
but I wanted to get
through it quickly
to tell you about a new result.
Just got accepted
to a conference
to appear in October.
Pretty soon.
And it's a project that started
in this class in the problem
session three years ago,
and we just solved it.
Took awhile.
Took another
co-author to chime in.
And it goes back to the
early history of fold and cut
which is simple folds.
All the magicians were
using simple folds.
What can you make
with simple folds?
Now you've been wowed and dowed
that you could make anything
with arbitrary folds, but simple
folds you cannot make anything.
Because the first told
you make, say, this one,
has to be a line of
symmetry of your diagram.
Got to stop making my life hard.
If you can fold something,
you can never unfold it.
That's the usual
simple fold model.
This has to line
up-- the cuts you
want to line up over
here, that are exactly
be the cuts you want
to line up here.
So you can only make
symmetric diagrams.
The first fold has to be a
line of reflectional symmetry.
But is that the only
property you need?
No.
Kind of have to have symmetry
for while until you're done.
How do you formalize that?
Well, we came up
with an algorithm
that in polynomial time,
an efficient algorithm
will tell you whether a
given polygon can be made.
Like this polygon looks good.
I think-- yeah, I
think this can be made.
So I think I would fold
along and do a bisector here,
and then this
basically disappears.
Folding over.
Then I would fold along
and get a bisector here,
and then this
disappears into that,
and then maybe I can fold here.
Does that work?
Barely.
I mean I've got to make sure
that this blank paper does not
come onto that.
But if that's a
problem, I can probably
make-- I could make a
fold here, for example.
Shrinks that up.
There's lots of
things you can do.
This is a borderline case
whether it's yes or no.
I will give you an
algorithm that does it.
For polygons with margin.
Bit of a technical condition.
Something that is
pretty typical.
What I mean is the thing
you're trying to cut out
does not meet the
boundary of the paper.
There's no margin here.
It'd be hard to print out.
So I really want
something that has margin.
That's a typical
case we care about.
We actually need this
for the proof to work.
We also need that
it's a single polygon.
It does not work
with general graphs.
This algorithm.
Because more complicated
things can happen.
It might be [INAUDIBLE].
for all we know,
the general case.
So here's the algorithm that
I'll give you in number form.
First thing you do is
guess the first fold.
This is a powerful
idea that even
most algorithmisists
don't necessarily know.
The idea is what could
the first fold be?
Has to be a line of
reflection symmetry.
Turns out there's a linear
number [INAUDIBLE] most.
You can find them
in linear time.
All these good algorithms
for finding them.
But which fold do I make first?
The answer is I don't care.
Let's just try them
all one at a time.
This is what I call guessing.
Just imagine from now on
that we made the right guess,
but if you end up failing
later on this algorithm,
just go back here
try the next one.
There's only N of them to try.
So you're going to
multiply the running time
of the rest of the algorithm
by N, and if this is N to N
squared-- which I think
the rest of the algorithm
is N squared-- the whole
algorithm will be N cubed
because you just run
this over and over
for each possible first fold.
We don't have a great theory
to find the first fold.
Just try them all.
That's step one.
Step two-- that's the only
guess we're going to make.
Fold down to convex hull.
This is a central idea.
So we have this polygon
we want to make.
There's all this
extra blank paper.
I don't like extra blank paper.
Just get rid of it.
Make lots of folds to fold
the blank paper onto itself
until it gets so tiny it just
goes slightly around the convex
hull.
Convex hull is the
smallest convex polygon
that contains your shape.
So it'll be like that.
It'll reduce the
paper down to that.
And I do this a lot.
I might as well.
It makes the problem easier
because I have less blank space
to worry about.
Blank space is a problem
because if I [? fold ?]
blank space onto
a cut, it's bad.
It's not allowed.
So the next thing we do is make
the best possible safe fold.
I need to define
that, but a safe fold
is just the folds
we're trying to make,
which is locally they
are lines of symmetry.
So like this one was a good
fold after I made this fold.
So this is-- all the
right stuff here is gone.
It's a good fold because
it folds this on to this,
and it folds blank space
onto this blank space.
So anything that comes into-- on
top of each other is identical.
That's a safe fold.
And repeat.
That's the algorithm.
How does that work?
Why does this work?
So it's the obvious
algorithm, basically.
It says make safe folds
until you're done.
If you finish, then you're done.
And then the answer's yes.
If you don't finish-- which
is a little hard to check
because you can always
make microscopic folds--
but you take the
limit and-- if it's
possible to do this
in polynomial time--
you find that out.
Turns out I can't finish
by making safe folds.
Then you can show
that actually there
was no way to make that
pattern by simple folds.
So let me give you an
idea of why that's true.
After I make a single
fold-- the first fold--
my picture looks like this.
It's no longer a polygon.
It's like half a polygon.
It ends at the
boundary of the paper.
It begins and ends with
the boundary of paper,
and you have some
chain in the middle.
We call this a passage.
It's like a path
you wander along.
And I want to somehow bring
all those edges into alignment.
Here I'm already
using it as a polygon.
If it weren't a polygon,
there might be more than one
of these.
Now I want to make a fold.
For example, this fold is
safe because it folds this
on to this, and it folds
blank space onto blank space
if I do it right.
And keep doing that.
Now when I make a fold
like this, what happens
is I can think of this region
that I folded-- the smaller
side-- as disappearing.
It just got absorbed
into the paper here.
So the graph that I was
trying to line up got smaller.
That's clearly a good thing.
Makes my problem easier.
The piece of paper I was
folding also got smaller.
That's a good thing.
But that's not always true.
Suppose you had a piece
of paper like this,
which could happen
after a bunch folding,
and then you fold
along a line like that
because, for
example, your passage
looks like that or something.
When I make the fold--
this has to go off.
When I make the fold I
get this crazy thing.
Not drawn to scale.
And this polygon does not
fit inside this polygon.
So my paper got
bigger in some places.
And that's a worry, because
now I have the stuff--
maybe it happens
to be blank space.
Maybe there's other
junk that got out here.
And now have to worry
about collisions
with this bigger piece of paper.
And this is always
our sticking point,
but there's some
magic you can do.
In fact, the picture
cannot look like this.
Because, look, you've got
some portion of your passage
to the left of the crease.
You've got some portion of
the passage to the right.
One of them has to be shorter.
Plus, this is a
line of symmetry.
So wherever I have a portion
of my passage over here,
I will have a portion
of my passage over here
until I run out of length.
One of them is shorter.
So the shorter one like this
one gets totally absorbed
by the larger one.
So the shorter side
always disappears.
So in this picture, I have
the long side of my passage,
and it's really a
subset of the original.
If I reduce this
to the convex hull,
like this, this
stuff disappears.
And in general, if you do
this fold down to convex hull,
this repeat goes
back to step two.
If you fold down
to the convex hull,
you can show that not only
does your passage-- the thing
you want to cut out-- get
smaller, but you piece of paper
also gets smaller.
Guaranteed.
And once you know the paper get
smaller and your things you're
trying to align get smaller, you
know that every move is safe.
So you never get stuck by
following this algorithm.
This works for
polygons with margin,
but not in any other situation
as far as we can tell.
Cool.
The last thing I
wanted to leave you on
is going out a little way
from regular 2D flat sheets
of paper.
You can generalize
and go up a dimension
to folding polyhedra surface.
Here, a surface of a polyhedron.
You've probably done this.
You take a cereal box and
you can collapse it flat.
Is that always possible?
It's called the flattening
problem, and the answer is yes.
And you can think of it
as a fold and cut problem,
because of the fold
and cut problem,
you have some polygon
like this diamond.
You make some
collection of folds
that brings the boundary
of the diamond to align.
So if you forget
about what's happening
on the inside of
the paper-- you just
look at the boundary
of the paper-- you're
folding that one-dimensional
boundary so that it collapses
down to a single line.
What I want to do is
this up a dimension.
I take a 3D cube of
paper-- solid cube.
I have embedded within
it some polygons
that I want to bring
to a common plane.
And I want to fold the solid
cube through four dimensions,
but flat so it ends up
back in three dimensions.
I get a different 3D solid,
but with multiple layers
right on top of each
other-- little bit
a fourth dimension
hanging out there.
But if I just look
at what's happening
to the boundary
of my polyhedron--
say I start with a dodecahedron
or something embedded
in there-- and I want
to fold this thing
so all the sides
of the dodecahedron
come to a common plane.
That is the 3D
folding cup problem.
It remains unsolved.
I suspect it's possible to solve
even with straight skeletons
and perpendiculars,
but it's really hard
to draw the pictures.
So we have not resolved
that one way or the other.
But the boundary
problem-- forget
about what's happening to
the interior and the exterior
of the dodecahedron.
If you just look at the
surface of the dodecahedron,
that you can fold
in 3D-- we think--
and you can show
and burn in haze
from the complexity proof
a couple lectures ago,
and also on this disk-packing
method with our co-authors.
They prove just two
years ago that if you
have any orientable manifold,
which is things like polyhedron
but no Mobius strips, no Klein
bundles, and other ugly things.
They have to be
manifold, so you're not
allowed to join three triangles
together along a single edge.
That would be forbidden.
So it's locally flat.
In such a case, you
can flatten the thing.
And the proof is very similar to
the disk-packing method of fold
and cut, and in the
textbook we talk
about how do you apply
that to do something
that's just like a sphere.
A regular polyhedron.
That's pretty easy to do
with the disk-packing method.
They generalize it
to the case where
you have polyhedral doughnuts
and all sorts of fun things.
But there's tons of
open problems here.
So we know how to
flatten surfaces,
and that's useful for things
like folding airbags flat.
But can you fold
the 3D solid flat?
You can think of--
we have here 1D edges
which we are collapsing
to a 1D line.
There is also zero
dimensional points here,
which we don't bring
to a single point.
It'd be nice if you could--
the generalized fold and cup
problem is you take a
D dimensional thing,
and you have all of
these-- there's 0, 1, 2,
3-- up to D dimensional
parts to it--
or D minus
one-dimensional parts.
You want to bring each of
them down into alignment
so that all the vertices
come to common point,
all the edges come
to a common line,
all the two-dimensional
faces come to a common plane,
and so on up the
dimension hierarchy.
That is the ultimate
open problem.
I think we end the book with
it, and it's totally unsolved.
Any questions?
That's folding
and cutting paper,
and next time we'll
start linkages.